- How time flies, not
to mention seagulls.
We all took it on the chin
again in 2021, but no one more
literally than this
teenager, riding the Spring
Shot on the Jersey Shore.
Still, there was
plenty to celebrate.
- Oh!
- And Tom Brady did
it by daring not
to go deep underwater with the
Lombardi Super Bowl trophy.
Another guy also
known for his hands
was Bernie Sanders, whose
mittens at the inauguration
became one of the first
big memes of 2021.
In fashion, Balenciaga
combined comfort and torture
with $625 high-heeled crocs.
- Fashion is about
a double-take.
You want people to
look and look again.
- A Massachusetts
man looked and looked
again for his missing
AirPod after he
fell asleep using them.
Eventually, an X-ray
located it in his esophagus,
and it was extracted.
- The audio works perfectly.
But sadly, yeah, the
microphone is a bit glitchy.
- At least he didn't glue his
eyes shut like this Michigan
woman who meant to
reach for eye drops
but used fingernail
glue instead.
This contact lens may
have saved her vision.
Maybe you think
you're seeing double.
Dwayne "The Rock"
Johnson fans were rocked
by this Alabama
Patrol Lieutenant
who even sounds like The Rock.
- Can you smell.
DWAYNE JOHNSON: --what
The Rock is cooking?
- And this Secret Service
agent protecting the Bidens
went viral just for being hot.
[music playing]
A dead ringer for Tom Cruise.
The Pope needed no
protection from Spider-Man,
an Italian guy who dresses up
to entertain kids in hospitals.
Nicole Richie
avoided the hospital,
even though she managed
to catch her hair on fire.
Forget the candles.
Blow out Nicole.
A Burger King manager
and eight staffers
blew off steam by quitting
very publicly with this sign,
while Rudy Giuliani wouldn't
quit shaving in public
at Delta's JFK lounge.
The guy who shot
this spectacle said--
- I was delighted and horrified.
- The same could be said
of combination foods
from Fruit Loops
pizza to popcorn salad
to candy corn bratwurst.
Of course, animals
stole the show.
Noodle the Pug prognosticator
predicted good or bad days
by his willingness to get up.
- Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
There are bones.
There are bones today.
- Decreeing either
bones or no bones days.
- Oh, a soft collapse.
- Doggy makeover
of the year goes
to this guy found wandering
in Kansas City, Missouri.
They removed 6 and 1/2
pounds of matted fur.
He had to relearn to walk.
And his new owners say all that
hair even affected his tail.
- It basically wags one way.
- Then there's the tail--
[loud crash]
--of the deer in Virginia
that leaped onto a school bus,
landing on a sleeping student.
They made an unscheduled
stop to drop him off.
2021 saw some unusual
Guinness records.
The biggest mouth, 5.7
inches, the most M&Ms, stacked
on each other, a measly five.
- Oh, oh!
- I've got to admit.
I did eat them all.
- The longest dog ears,
Lou the Coonhound's ears
measured 13.38 inches each.
All through our interview, she
kept staring off to the side.
- She is staring at herself.
- In a glass door.
Of course, the end of
the year is a great time
for self-reflection.
How do others see me?
- Can you hear me, judge?
- I can hear you.
I think it's a filter.
- A Texas lawyer
using his assistant's
computer during a hearing heard
himself coming out of a feline.
- I'm here live.
I'm not a cat.
- At least the cat
didn't get his tongue.
Jeanne Moos, CNN, New York.